[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur rt france pour la grande interview
spéciale diego maradona quel lien à la
politique pour la légende du foot
argentin et mondiale décédé le 25
novembre dernier
on en parle avec pascal boniface
fondateur et directeur de l'iris
institut des relations internationales
et stratégiques géopolitologue bonjour
pascal boniface
bonjour vous êtes l'un des initiateurs
de la géopolitique dans le sport dans le
foot donc vous connaissez évidemment
très bien diego maradona maradona plus
qu'un footballeur une légende dans un
pays exemple l'argentine qui renégocie
par exemple en ce moment sa dette avec
le fonds monétaire international le fmi
quelle image il laisse de l'ue diego
maradona en argentine il laisse une
image bas du d'une icône absolue d'un
dieu vivant parce que il a porté très
haut les couleurs d'un pays qui était
humiliée par la guerre des malouines en
82 qui sentait d'une dictature
un pays qui se sentaient méprisés et a
abandonné un peu de tout c'est grâce à
maradona ce pays a gagné la coupe du
monde par ailleurs en battant l'équipe
d'angleterre en quarts de finale ce qui
est peut-être une victoire dans la
victoire et surtout il a gagné
finalement avec une équipe où il était
vraiment à papa isolé parce qu'il y
avait d'autres joueurs talentueux dans
l'équipe mais on peut dire que maradona
beaucoup plus porté l'équipe d'argentine
que pelé n'a porté l'équipe du brésil
brésil était beaucoup plus accompagné de
talent que maradona l'état et donc c'est
vraiment grâce à maradona que
l'argentine à gaillac ou du monde comme
c'est grâce à maradona que naples a
gagné 2 scudetto à la fin des années 80
vous venez de parler de la guerre des
malouines
évidemment on se souvient de ce côté à
la fois sportif avec le foot à la fois
politique même géopolitique j'ai envie
de dire avec cette victoire face à face
à l'angleterre avec cette guerre qui
avait eu lieu quelques quelques années
auparavant est ce que c'est une revanche
politique une revanche militaire pour
diego maradona et pour l'argentine face
à face à face à l'angleterre ce que la
politique et le sport font finalement
bon ménage
oui bien sûr alors c'est pas une vie
corps militaire mais c'est une revanche
politique et sportif sur une défaite
militaire est effectivement alors que
le pl et n'arrêtait pas de dire qu'il
fallait pas mélanger sport et politique
maradona revendiquait de mélanger sport
et politique et cette victoire sur
l'angleterre en 86 avec deux bus un but
qui est restée dans les annales sans
doute peut-être comme le plus beau but
qui n'est jamais été marqués dans une
coupe du monde le deuxième où maradona
dribble six joueurs anglais en partant
de 70 mètres du but avant de marquer
c'est vraiment un but magnifique mais
maradona préféré le premier but le
premier but qu'il a marqué qu il a
marqué de la main en trichant donc en ne
respectant pas les règles parce qu'il y
avait un côté un peu il le disait
lui-même c'est comme piqué le
portefeuille dans la poche d'un anglais
c'était quand même une une vengeance sur
novateur une revanche et donc
l'argentine regagnait sur le terrain du
football
ce qu'elle avait perdu sur le terrain
militaire c'est la fameuse la fameuse
main de dieu là vous êtes en train de
dire finalement diego maradona c'est
l'homme du peuple vous parliez tout à
l'heure de de naples 1 le club avec qui
il avait joué avec qui il a remporté des
titres
naples c'est la ville du sud on parle du
mezzogiorno en italie la ville du sud en
guerre a en tous les cas un rebelle face
aux villes du nord le triangle le fameux
triangle industriel milan turin gêne il
a joué au barça le fc barcelone face au
real à l'époque et qui incarnait le
franquisme
et puis à boca juniors évidemment le
club du peuple à buenos aires et face à
river plate le club des riches donc
diego maradona icône du pape c'est ça
c'était un homme de gauche
alors oui c'était un homme d'ultra
gauche tu as un côté lors il n'a pas son
qu'il sortait lui-même d'un milieu très
défavorisé des bas quartiers de meneau
ça irait c'est effectivement comme vous
l'avez remarqué il a toujours joué dans
des clubs qui incarnait la révolte par
rapport au pouvoir central barcelone
effectivement incarnait la résistance
sort au club madrilène
la critique quand quelqu'un de franco et
réels qui incarnait peu ou prou quand
même le franquisme
annappes c'est effectivement le club
méprisait le sud méprisés par le nord
qui prend sa revanche sur le terrain est
d'ailleurs dans la coup du monde en 90
il sera sifflée par le public italien ce
qui va vraiment le lui portait vraiment
le toucher énormément et quand ils
devaient venir en france il était
question il devait venir à marseille
là aussi la ville rebelle contre la
capitale donc il ya toujours un carnet
cela et dans ses prises de position on
connaît sa proximité avec castro on
connaît sa proximité avec hugo chavez
il a aussi rencontré lula mais il allait
vraiment à l'ultra gauche parce que
castro et chavez c'est beaucoup plus que
la gauche parce qu'il y avait aussi
finalement la révolte contre les états
unis
les etats-unis qui avaient été du côté
de l'angleterre dans la guerre des
malouines
malgré le traité un terrain mis qu'un
d'assistance réciproque et les argentins
avaient vécu comme une trahison de la
part des états unis que les s'agit se
met du côté de du royaume uni et puis
aussi les saillies de bouche qui dans
les années 2000 fait la guerre d'irak et
en 2005 maradona dans un sommet à terre
américain aura même des propos
insultants à l'égard de georges bush
il n'avait pas un langage diplomatique
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire
justement vous parlez de george bush
s'en souvient de cette tournée de l'ex
président des états unis en 2004 en
amérique du sud diego maradona à
l'époque arboraient un tee shirt war
criminal c'est à dire criminel criminels
de guerre mais en quoi il était si anti
américain on a parlé de ses liens avec
les figures de l'ultra gauche
sud-américaine bolivarienne fidel castro
hugo chavez nicolás maduro evo morales
ou encore lula en quoi ils étaient six
américains
diego 6 ici anti américain parce que les
états unis représentaient la domination
des mecs latine est effectivement dans
le monde occidental chavez et castro
n'ont pas bonne presse c'est le moins
que l'on puisse dire mais en est mais
katyn il incarne au delà de leur régime
politique qu'il incarne la résistance au
rouleau compresseur américain essence en
cela qu'il est populaire et c'est pour
cela que maradona est et se coter à
maradona a rencontré fidel castro en 87
ils allaient recevoir un prix
récompensant le meilleur joueur latino
américains il a rencontré castro il est
tombé sous son charme
et puis il a fait après dans à partir de
2002 long séjour à cuba des séjours
sanitaire parce que il venait y soigner
ses addictions et donc il avait une
vraie proximité humaine il a eu une
longue conversation avec castro on ne
peut pas dire que maradona est un
théoricien de la gauche c'était plutôt
quelqu'un qui vivait des intuitions et
des passions et qui s'est exprimé haut
et fort bon non pas d'un point de vue
théorique une fois encore mais il avait
cette sensibilité cette sensibilité de
ne pas oublier la de là d'où il venait
et de toujours incarné bien les dix
khamis à dos les sans-chemise les
pauvres par rapport ce qui représente le
pouvoir la richesse on peut dire que
castro était au pouvoir
mais il a pris le pouvoir contre les
américains comme chavez qui était
s'étaient opposés contre les héros aux
états unis et evo morales que vous avez
cités effectivement qui lui était en
plus amérindiens comme chavez par
ailleurs il avait déclaré diego maradona
du site avec castro chavez boula
kirchner je crois qu'on peut former une
bonne alliance contre la pauvreté la
corruption et rompre la relation filiale
avec les états unis ça vous évoque quoi
pour aller plus loin dans cette dans
cette analyse
oui alors disons que kirscher ce n'était
pas le meilleur modèle pour lutter
contre la corruption puisque les couples
kirchner a été pris à plusieurs reprises
la main dans le pot mais comme il est
incarné la gauche en argentine maradona
est elle proche effectivement des
cercles péroniste alors on ne peut pas
tout à fait les comparer parce que lula
lui avait des bonnes relations il s'est
opposé à jean je bouge quand même temps
il avait voulu maintenir une relation
avec les états unis alors que morales
chavez et bien sûr castro était dans une
position frontale
néanmoins il y avait aussi celle où là
le fait que les l'amérique latine devait
prendre son indépendance par rapport aux
états unis et lula avait beaucoup fait
pour que l'alena l'accord de
libre-échange latino américains ne
soient pas signé et préservé il avait
plutôt lui développé le mercosur et il
avait fait échec au projet d'un traité
global de libre échange sur l'ensemble
du continent latino américain
diego maradona donc figure de l'ultra
gauche sud américaine ont pourtant
escape a un côté paradoxal on souvient
d'une interview à l'époque du
journaliste de france télévisions gérard
holtz et diego maradona lui répondait si
on ne marque pas de buts on ne gagne pas
d'argent il disait également en parlant
de lui à la troisième personne
je ne pense pas que diego maradona vos 5
milliards mais beaucoup plus sans
oublier les pubs de diego maradona pour
coca cola pour puma ou encore mcdonald's
c'est ce qui a pas un côté paradoxal est
ce que c'est pas un peu là la gauche
caviar finalement de diego maradona ah
bah oui effectivement comme tout enfin
c'était une icône mondiale et il était
riche ici parce que tout le monde se
précipitait d'ailleurs à l'époque il ya
quand même moins d'argent dans le
football que maintenant il serait encore
plus riches s'ils avaient joué
maintenant et si on compare les contrats
de neymar et ceux de maradona y'a pas
photo même si maradona marquera plus
l'histoire que neymar là marquera mais
effectivement il profitait du système et
il n'allait pas refuser les sommes qu'il
était donné et puis il avait un ego
comme beaucoup de vedettes mondiales il
avait un ego démesuré mais je dirais
qu'il n'allait pas refuser les contrats
qu'on lui proposait après il a fait un
peu de redistribution quand même
mais effectivement il a profité du
système et pourquoi vouloir s'afficher
tout le temps aux côtés de figures
politiques on se souvient notamment en
2018 il avait été l'invité d'honneur de
de vladimir poutine en russie
on se souvient également qu'ils étaient
proches aussi avec saadi kadhafi le fils
de mouammar kadhafi pourquoi un lien
comme cela avec des figures politiques
alors quand même qu'ils sont très
différentes entre poutine et kadhafi ya
quand même une marge de manoeuvre
je pense que en fait par atavisme il
était intéressé par tout ce qui est anti
américain et donc dès qu'il y avait un
leader qui affichait un anti
américanisme il y allait et bien sûr
c'était kadhafi s'était un peu quand
même différent en termes de personnalité
que les autres et donc il était
tellement animé par une opposition
viscérale aux états unis qu'il ne
regardait pas trop de même qu'il s'est
montré dans les derniers temps auprès de
loukachenko ce qui n'était pas forcément
un choix très judicieux parce que
loukachenko n'a pas la même résonance
que castro evo morales unguja baisse
notamment en amérique latine il ya une
personne qui failli à beaucoup de
personnes évidemment qu'ils sont
exprimés publiquement après la mort de
diego maradona mais mais en france une
des figures de la gauche de l'ultra
gauche jean luc mélenchon il a dit
exactement je cite c'était aussi un
compagnon de combat fortune ou pas
maradona était resté du côté du peuple
maradona l'attaquant alors est ce qu'on
peut dire que
mélenchon est le récupérateur le milieu
récupérateur qui fait de la récupération
politique
non parce que pour jean luc mélenchon
quelqu'un qui est proche de chavez de
castro et de evo morales est forcément
en calcul dont il se sent proche et puis
alors on peut bien sûr critiquer la
fortune des footballeurs mais on peut
aussi penser que c'est bien de sa part
de faire des choix enfin que c'est un
peu courageux de sa part de sortir de la
langue de bois de ne pas se planquer
derrière des discours convenus alors il
a eu ses excès aussi bien sur le plan
personnel etc
c'est ça maradona en fait c'est aussi
c'est pour cela qu'il frappe tant les
esprits c'est que le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que le personnage
n'est pas lisse et qui a de multiples
aspérités et donc ça ne l'est pas il
n'est pas du tout étonnant que mélenchon
se sentent une proximité par rapport à
maradona
même si je ne pense pas que mélenchon
soit un adorateur du football spectacle
et du football professionnel
mais ce sont les prises de position
politiques de maradona qui en fait marc
la différence parce que dans le milieu
des stars à ça du football c'est
peut-être l'un des rares qui s'affiche
avec des figures d'extrême gauche
pascal boniface on arrive au terme de
cette grande interview si vous aviez un
mot pour conclure pour qualifier diego
maradona un adjectif ce serait lequel
chapeau l'artiste parce que quand même
il a il a fait rêver
il a redonné sa fierté elle de nombreux
argentins nombreux latino-américains et
c'était un pur plaisir de le voir jouer
donc effectivement il ya eu c'est son
côté plus sombre et c'est pour ça que
c'est un personnage de légende
parce que il avait le côté extrêmement
brillant et les aspects plus sombres
merci pascal boniface pour ce décryptage
complet au sujet de diego maradona qui
nous a donc quitté à la fin novembre
merci pour avoir répondu à toutes ses
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
fondateur le directeur de l'iris et
géopolitologue notamment du sport donc
merci à pascal boniface c'est la fin de
cette grande interview on se retrouve
plus tard évidemment sur rt france by
[Musique]